behind some of the coolest premium
effects in hollywood content is the
invisible aid of ai artificial
intelligence it is just blowing the
doors wide open on opportunities for new
ways to tell stories this is a good
technology to hang our hat on because it
is getting so much better every single
year machine learning is being baked
into workflows helping create previously
unimaginable moments from big
blockbusters to non-fiction tv i think
where ai really is impactful is getting
it to do things that human beings can't
do including raising the dead as if you
know you had andy warhol standing in the
studio right in front of you and you
looked at him and said i want you to say
it like like this i wasn't very close to
anyone although i guess i wanted to be
let's examine a few specific use cases
of how ai is changing hollywood's
creative workflow
[Music]
the entertainment industry was spawned
by new technology so it makes sense that
from talkies to television to digital
video hollywood has a history of
leveraging new tech especially in the
world of visual effects when i saw
jurassic park that was the moment that i
realized that computer graphics would
change the face of storytelling forever
in the last 25 years that i've been
working in film we've been conquering
various challenges doing digital water
for the first time in titanic doing
digital faces for the first time in a
movie like benjamin button and now the
state of the art is machine learning ai
applications like the kind matt's
company mars develops in-house you can
throw it you know infinite amount of
data and it will find the patterns in
that data naturally thanks to thirsty
streaming services hollywood is
scrambling to feed demand for premium
content rich and visual effects budgets
time are not growing in a way that
corresponds to those rising quality
expectations it's outpacing the number
of artists that are available to do the
work and that's where ai comes in
tackling time-consuming uncreative tasks
like denoising rotoscoping and motion
capture tracking removal
this was our first time ever trying ai
in a production we had a lot of footage
just by virtue of being on the project
and doing 400 shots for marvel when we
received the footage which we call the
plates in order to
manipulate paul bettney's face there
needed to be tracking markers during
principal photography we looked at it we
said okay well removing tracking markers
is going to take roughly one day per
shot in order to replace or partially
replace vision's head for each shot and
a shot is typically defined as about
five seconds of footage the tracking
marker removal itself was about a tenth
of that so on a 10-day shot one day was
simply removing tracking markers we
developed a neural net where we are able
to identify the dots on the face the
artificial intelligence averaged out the
skin texture around the dot removed the
dot and then infilled with the average
of the texture surrounding it and marvel
loved it because it sped up production
they saved money it's exactly what we
wanted these solutions to do where the
solution was faltering was whenever
there was motion blur when paul betty
moves his head very quickly to the right
or to the left there's moments where
those dots will reappear partially
because in the data set itself we didn't
have enough motion blur data another
example would be whenever the character
turned his head where his eyes were out
of the screen
you would see those dots reappear as
well the ai recognition it's using the
eyes as a kind of a crucial landmark to
identify the face and so if i turn my
head this way and you can't see my eyes
well the ai can't identify that as a
face again you can fix those things with
more data the more data you feed these
things typically the better right
there wasn't a lot of clean data
available on our next ai use case the
star of the film had been dead for 25
years yet the director wanted more than
30 pages of dialogue read by iconic
artist andy warhol himself so what do
you do you could hire like a voice actor
to do like a great impersonation
but we found with his voices you kind of
wanted to retain
that humanness that andy had himself you
can get fairly close with the voice
actor but you really can't get it so and
that's where ai technology really helps
generative audio is the ability for a
artificial agent to be able to reproduce
a particular voice but also reproduce
the style the delivery the tone of a
real human being and do it in real time
welcome to resemble a generative audio
engine when the team initially reached
out to us they proposed what they were
going to do we asked them like okay well
what kind of data are we working with
and they sent us these audio files like
recordings over a telephone they're all
from the late 70s mid 70s the thing
about machine learning is that bad data
hurts a lot more than good data so i
remember looking at the data we had
available and thinking this is going to
be really really difficult to get right
with three minutes of data we're being
asked to produce six episodes worth of
content with three minutes of his voice
so with three minutes he hasn't said
every word that's out there so we're
able to extrapolate to other phonetics
and to other words and our algorithm is
able to figure out how andy would say
those words that's where neural networks
are really powerful they basically take
that speech data and they break it down
and they understand hundreds and
thousands of different features from it
once we have that voice that sounds like
andy from those three minutes of data
then it's all about delivery it's all
about performance i went down to the
office because they're making a robot of
me and andy's voice it's highly
irregular and that's where the idea of
style transfer really came in so style
transfer is this ability
for our algorithm to take input as voice
and someone else's speech i wasn't very
close to anyone although i guess i
wanted to be we're able to say that line
and then our algorithms are able to
extract certain features out of that
delivery and apply it to andy's
synthetic or target voice the first one
was like automatically generated no
touch-ups i wasn't very close to anyone
although i guess i wanted to be the
second one was like touch up by adding a
pause i wasn't very close to anyone
although i guess i wanted to be and then
the third one was basically adding the
final touch where it's like okay you
know what i really want to place an
emphasis on this particular syllable so
yeah let's get a voice actor to do that
part to actually place that emphasis on
the right words right syllable and then
the third output has those features
extracted from that voiceover actor and
to andy's voice i wasn't very close to
anyone although i guess i wanted to be
you have definitely heard ai voices
being used in the past for touch-ups for
a line here or there this is probably
the first major project that's using it
so
most vfx is still a very manual process
characters can be extremely challenging
creatures things like fur hair those
things can be extremely challenging and
time consuming one notable example of
where the technology is headed are the
scenes involving advanced 3d vfx in
avengers endgame
josh brolin plays thanos we capture tons
and tons of data in this laboratory
setting with josh and then we use that
data to train neural networks inside of
a computer to learn
how josh's face moves they'll say lines
they'll look left they'll look right
they'll go through silly expressions and
we capture an immense amount of detail
in that laboratory setting then they can
go to a movie set and act like
they normally would act they don't have
to wear any special equipment sometimes
they wear a head camera but it's really
lightweight stuff very unobtrusive and
allows the actors to act like they're in
a normal movie then later when the
animators go to animate the digital
character they kind of tell the computer
what expression the actor wants to be in
and the computer takes what it knows
based on this really dense set of data
and uses it to plus up to enhance what
the visual effects animator has done and
make it look completely real
[Music]
so there will come a time in the future
maybe it's 10 years maybe it's 15 years
but you will see
networks that are going to be able to do
really creative stuff again that's not
to suggest that you remove talented
artists from the equation but i mean
that's the bet that we're taking as a
business is ai going to take over my job
what i see happening right now is
actually quite the opposite is that it
is creating new opportunities for us to
spend the time
on doing things that are creatively
meaningful rather than spending lots of
time doing menial tasks we're actually
able to focus on the creative things and
we have more time for iteration we can
experiment more creatively to find the
best looking result i think that the
more that ai can do the menial stuff for
us the more we're going to find
ourselves being creatively fulfilled
again the argument for us is like really
creating
content that isn't humanly possible so
you know we're not interested in like
creating an ad spot
that a real voice actor would do because
in all honesty
that real voice actor would do
way better than the ai technology would
do would be way faster if you're just
delivering a particular sentence or a
particular line the technology to do
deep fakes is is so prevalent you can
get apps on your phone now that pretty
much can do a rudimentary deep fake it's
going to be interesting in the future
are we going to have to put limits on
this technology how do we really verify
what's authentic and what isn't there
are sort of social repercussions for it
as well that i think that we don't quite
understand yet i absolutely believe that
this technology could be misused our
number one priority is to make everyone
feel comfortable what we're doing i
think it comes down to educating the
general population eventually and making
them understand that they should think
through whatever they are looking at
whatever they're reading and now
whatever they're hearing we feel we're
directionally correct in our bet that
this is a good technology to hang our
hat on because it is getting
so much better every single year and we
don't want to miss what we see as like a
once in a lifetime opportunity here